this is from the ap it says a man held
hostages for more than 10 hours saturday
at a texas synagogue where he could be
heard ranting in a live stream and
demanding the release of a pakistani
neuroscientist who was convicted of
trying to kill us army officers in
afghanistan one of the four hostages
held at congregation beth israel in
colleyville was released during the
standoff three others were rescued when
authorities entered the building around
9pm uh the hosta taker was killed and
fbi special agent in charge matt desarno
said a team would investigate the
shooting incident
law enforcement officials who were not
authorized to discuss the ongoing
investigation spoke to the ap on the
condition of anonymity
uh said that the hosta taker demanded
the release of um afiya siddiqui a
pakistani neuroscientist suspected of
having ties to al qaeda now
the name of the terrorist in this case
is malik faisal
akram and uh usually we don't like to
show you you know these terrorists and
everything and what they look like and
we don't want to put their their names
and faces all over the place but i do
want to show you in this case what he
looks like because it's important
context here's what he looks like
and you have to see that because funny
enough all of the corporate media
outlets
have been describing him for for days
now as um simply a british man that's
what they're
that's how they that's the description
they decided to go with a british man
that's all we need to know about is he's
from britain
in fact early on uh i forget which
outlet it was but one of them actually
described him as a man with a british
accent and that's how they decided to
describe now
if he had um if he had a middle eastern
accent an accent to reflect his his uh
ethnic background
do you think anyone any headline would
describe him that way man with a middle
eastern
accent takes hostages not going to
happen
now we were also told even though
he actually said what his motives were
so we know that this is is an islamic
radical
um he's taking hostages on behalf of of
another terrorist
and this is one of the there are times
when motives are unclear
right the las vegas shooting
um
hundreds of people shot
we still haven't been told his motive
because as far as we as we know he never
said anything to anybody about it
so the motive is very unclear now many
of us have been asking for years now hey
what was that all about remember that
guy that shot all those people in las
vegas why did that happen
but the fbi and uh law enforcement
officials they claim that oh you know
who knows man it just happened
so there are there are
times when the motive is unclear
there are times when it seems like the
powers that be don't don't want us to
know the motive but this is a case where
he actually said
what his motive was
which is pretty common for hostage
takers there's what whatever they have
they have a reason why they're doing it
they're trying to accomplish something
that's why they're taking hostages
and um usually they'll tell you what
they want and he did
and and yet
in the hours after that um fbi an fbi
spokesman got in front of cameras and
said uh well you know we we still don't
know what what this was about but but he
was not targeting the jewish community
is what we were told listen
uh we we do believe from our engagement
with this subject that he was singularly
focused on one issue
and it was not specifically related to
the jewish community but we're
continuing to work to find motive and we
will continue on that path
so the fbi is confused and joe biden the
next day was asked about this and uh he
was also just confounded i mean he had
no idea why this happened listen to
biden
well no i don't we don't have i don't
think there is
sufficient information to know about
why he
targeted that synagogue why he insisted
on the release of someone who's been in
prison for over uh 10 years why he was
engaged why he
was using anti-semitic and anti-israeli
comments uh i i we just don't have
enough facts so let's see um
so we got a muslim guy
sister's a convicted terrorist takes
hostage at a synagogue takes hostages at
a synagogue in texas on a saturday
um
the sabbath
and uh ed but now it wasn't targeting
jews had nothing to that's just
coincidence
could have been anywhere right he could
have chosen any location just happens to
choose a synagogue in texas because you
know those are a dime a dozen
in texas so if you're just walking down
the street randomly looking for a place
to take hostages and
you you might
chances are you're going to stumble
across a synagogue
that's what we're supposed to believe of
course is totally absurd and um
a day after this
the fbi put another statement out and
now they're saying this is a
terrorism-related matter in which the
jewish community was targeted and is
being investigated by the joint
terrorism task force
so the fbi tried to say ah this was not
anti-jewish this was not you know let's
not let's not
jump to any conclusions
very quickly they changed their they
completely reversed course without any
explanation and the reason is they're
just being roundly mocked and ridiculed
and criticized for it so that's why they
decided to change that's what we get
from the fbi
um
meanwhile of course
whenever something like this happens
and you have a member of an approved
victim group
who does something terrible
um
we're told immediately that the number
one concern the number one priority is
to make sure that other members of that
group are not um blamed for it
or not made to feel uncomfortable
that's the number one priority after all
this happens
before we if people are killed before we
even put the bodies in the ground number
one priority is to protect the feelings
of the other members of that approved
victim group so the daily beast
columnist wajahat ali
hours later here's what he tweeted about
is what he was thinking immediately
after he said you're about to hear some
ugly and vicious islamophobia and
anti-muslim bigotry this weekend from
elected officials commentators and even
mainstream media hope i'm wrong people
will use it to divide jewish and muslim
communities for their political agenda
don't fall for it
um
many of them yeah because
right because it's the fault of um
conservative commentators that there's
division in the muslim and jewish
community
right
i mean historically it's really it's
really all the fault of
conservative bloggers and radio hosts
um
it wasn't it was it wasn't for us
there'd be nothing but peace and harmony
among the jewish and uh muslim
population globally
he continues many of them will claim to
care about jewish lives as they openly
support and parrot vile anti-semitic
conspiracies they don't care about our
lives or our communities
muslim is easy synonym for terrorists
and those who downplay january 6th will
now talk a lot about national security
so take a drink if you're playing the
january 6th drinking game
um maybe that'll be your first drink of
the day probably not you're probably
already
stupefied drunk but uh of course we had
to get the mention of january 6th in
there
so
what we know at the left is that the
only thing that matters is um the victim
narrative of course
and they have their victim hierarchy and
this kind of equation complicated
equation well oftentimes it's pretty
simple
you know
um the the victim narrative and the in
the equation is simple but there are
times when it becomes a little more
complicated for them and that's where
they start kind of stepping on their own
feet and and tripping and stumbling a
lot
and um that's what that's what we have
here
now i think in general for the left
for the left's victim narrative
they have a lot of trouble
with the jewish community
they're not they're
they're not quite sure what to do there
because obviously with the jews we're
talking about
a minority
um and a historically oppressed minority
clearly
uh but
if we're going based on skin
pigmentation especially in the united
states
you know they're white they look they
look just like any other white person
walking down the street and so that
means that they they they can't really
be included in the victim narrative
you know they they don't fall into the
victim equation
and then when you look at
conflicts overseas in the middle east
well that's where it becomes more simple
for them whoever has darker skin is the
is the victim
and um
and the victim is right you know the
victim group is always right in any
conflict
um
that's why they just can't they they
they cannot admit
um they can't go outside of the victim
narrative
and when anything happens this is always
the first concern so if there's a muslim
terrorist attack
first concern
is making sure that
nobody says any mean things to muslims
because of it
when china unleashes a deadly virus on
the world and kills five million people
what's the first concern there it's not
the whole china accountable that's for
sure
it's just to make sure there's no
anti-asian sentiment that's the biggest
problem
totally twisted and demented listen hit
that subscribe button right now do it
right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated